Trascrizione: Claudia Bottigelli
Revisore: Maria Pericleous
Ho sempre avuto paura di invecchiare.
Sempre.
Da quando ho memoria sento il tempo.
Soffro di una forma
di meteoropatia ossessiva.
Che piovano sassi o splenda la primavera,
io sono sempre lì, a odiare
il barometro dei giorni.
Non è questione di vecchiaia o gioventù,
è il passo pesante delle ore
che diventano settimane, poi mesi
e poi decenni, non lo sopporto.
Non sopporto l’erosione costante
e progressiva del mio giacimento di tempo.
Quel tesoretto che vi fa sentire ricchi
fino a vent’anni, se siete normali,
nemmeno a vent’anni se siete come me.
L’antipatia per la mortalità non è
un’acquisizione recente,
giustificata dalla mia
situazione anagrafica.
È un’ossessione antica e, per questo,
ha finito per diventare perfino elegante.
Non ho conosciuto i miei nonni,
non ho mai visto i miei genitori felici.
Quando i miei genitori
sono diventati vecchi,
ho provato per loro soltanto pena.
Pena e paura.
Mi sono formata la convinzione
che l’arco della vita sia spietato.
Pura perdita.
Ho provato ripugnanza per i corpi usurati,
per i riflessi ritardati,
per il passo incerto dei vecchi.
Mi sono promessa il suicidio.
Ho detto: “Deciderò io”.
Ho detto: “Non sono il tipo che subisce
la scomparsa progressiva della grazia.
Mi elimino prima che siano
gli altri a eliminarmi”.
All’età di 26 anni ho scritto
il mio secondo romanzo.
Il primo mi ha buttato
addosso il successo,
come un vestito inadatto alla mia età.
Si intitolava “Ammazzare il tempo”
il secondo romanzo.
Questa era l’epigrafe: “Non sei
né giovane né vecchio,
ma è come se dormissi dopo pranzo
sognando di entrambe queste età“.
Da “Misura per misura”,
William Shakespeare.
Avevo 26 anni e sognavo la vecchiaia,
e sognavo la giovinezza,
ed erano entrambe un incubo.
Avevo paura di invecchiare,
ma anche di prolungare l’adolescenza
al di là dei limiti imposti
dalla casa paterna,
dall’obbligo della scuola.
Volevo crescere,
e se ci tieni tanto a crescere,
prima o poi ti tocca di invecchiare.
Ho provato a rassegnarmi:
sarei stata vecchia.
Mi sono proposta,
con mezzo secolo di anticipo,
di attraversare a testa alta
anche quella terra desolata.
Ho deciso di pensare alla vita come
a un viaggio spaventoso e misterioso.
“Attraverserò paesi stranieri”,
- mi dicevo -
“ciascuno con la sua bellezza particolare.
Anche se lassù è sempre inverno e quaggiù
il sole pieno ti impedisce di riposare,
sarà meraviglioso viaggiare nel tempo.
Mi abituerò a usi e costumi diversi.
Infanzia, adolescenza, giovinezza,
maturità, vecchiaia!
Sono paesi separati.
Se si odiano l’uno con l’altro, la colpa
è degli stereotipi che li ingabbiano”.
Due paesi li avevo già alle spalle:
l’infanzia,
e l’adolescenza.
Potevo guardarli con
la nostalgia dei partenti.
Salutai me stessa ragazza
con obiettività.
Ero timida e sfrontata,
aggressiva per paura,
avevo le ginocchia ossute,
la pelle lucida, le lentiggini,
i capelli sottili, che scendevano
giù dalle spalle,
formando morbidezze non volute.
Avevo quei seni grandi,
che ti fanno incurvare la schiena.
L’addio alla ragazza l’ho celebrato
bevendo e scrivendo, fumando e scrivendo,
scrivendo e rifiutando
ogni forma di ricompensa,
per il coraggio con cui guardavo
il transitare inarrestabile di quel tempo,
a cui nessuno dei miei coetanei
prestava ancora la minima attenzione.
Liquidata la ragazza, sono entrata
nel paese degli adulti.
Con ansia.
Mi pareva terribile avere 27 anni.
Perché il confine con il nuovo paese
passava per i 27 anni,
e non per i 30 o i 25?
Perché avevo appena generato
con il mio corpo, il mio sangue
e la mia selvaggia distrazione
un altro essere umano.
E quello, veramente,
non è un gioco da ragazzi.
Dicono che gli adulti,
e tali sono considerati quelli
che hanno fra i 30 e i 55 anni,
siano i padroni del vapore,
se sono maschi naturalmente,
maschi dell’età di mezzo.
Sono loro l’uomo, l’umanità.
Le donne in quella stessa ormai
larga fascia d’età, verso la fine,
tra i 45 e i 55, incominciano a
differenziarsi duramente dall’universale,
che è ancora maschile,
spiace dirlo, ma è così.
Non solo non hanno lo stesso accesso
ai piani alti della società,
ma subiscono il primo affronto,
la prima diminuzione di integrità,
la prima offesa: la menopausa,
la fine dell’età feconda.
Gli uomini non sono sottoposti
alla stessa esperienza.
Fino a 55 anni sono giovani.
Dai 55 ai 65 meno giovani.
Dai 67 pensionati.
Il pensionamento li colpisce
nella loro identità,
spesso legata al lavoro,
ma l’odore mortifero
che si sprigiona dal ritiro,
dalla chiusura delle porte dell’ufficio
può essere contrastato
con altre passioni affermative.
Anche altri amori eventualmente.
Perché, conservando almeno
teoricamente la capacità di generare,
gli uomini non si presentano
sul terreno dell’eros diminuiti,
disfunzionali al sottotesto erotico
dell’amarsi e moltiplicarsi.
Restano umani gli uomini.
Le donne, al contrario, vengono private
di colpo, e crudelmente
proprio di ciò che le rendeva differenti
e più ricche, più complete.
Contenere nel proprio corpo il dispositivo
che perpetua la specie.
Si decida o no di metterlo in moto, c’è
e costituisce il senso della differenza,
direi anzi della supremazia femminile.
L’uomo scopre di essere diventato genitore
se riceve una telefonata.
La donna lo sa con la certezza del corpo.
Indipendentemente da come
arrivano all’appuntamento
con la fine della fertilità,
se madri o non madri,
con rimpianti o senza, felici o infelici,
le donne non vengono più
considerate donne intere
quando si interrompe
il loro flusso mestruale.
È il primo appuntamento con la vecchiaia
accade intorno ai 50 anni.
Ne vivono secondo statistica
minimo altri 36, spesso 40-45.
E sono anni difficili.
Possono diventare terribili
se non facciamo qualcosa.
Ecco.
È qui che vi volevo, qui che questa
simpatica lamentazione
diventa un grido di battaglia.
Che cosa possiamo fare?
Che cosa possiamo fare per smettere
di essere considerate merce scaduta
quando non ovuliamo più?
E, ancora prima, merce avariata perché
non indossiamo più la livrea prevista
per gli oggetti del desiderio maschile?
Prima di tutto dobbiamo lottare
contro gli stereotipi
che, dalla culla alla bara,
ci infilano nelle gabbie dell’età.
Che cosa sono gli stereotipi?
Espedienti cognitivi
che ci aiutano a interpretare
ciò che ci circonda
semplificando la complessità del reale.
Sono credenze e informazioni di comodo
mai verificate ma stabili
resistenti al cambiamento.
Gli stereotipi li vediamo
sulla nostra pelle,
minano la nostra salute mentale,
riducono le nostre aspettative,
ci rendono pavidi e conformisti.
Ogni età, invece di essere vissuta
come un viaggio eccitante
fra paesi stranieri,
diventa la stazione dolorosa
di una via crucis,
irta di aggettivi squalificativi.
Non è soltanto
la sempre aborrita terza età,
o la temuta quarta e ultima
a fare le spese degli stereotipi.
Ogni età ha la sua croce.
Ecco a voi alcuni esempi.
Dalla voce dei sepolti vivi nel cimitero
delle semplificazioni.
“Per tutta la vita ho avuto paura
di varcare la soglia della vecchiaia.
Era un territorio di sconfinata mestizia,
dove la malattia, la noia e la morte,
come tre mostri di antica bruttezza,
scacciavano la vita,
chiudevano le porte,
o almeno così credevo.”
Lidia, 1951.
“Ho 13 anni e tutti si aspettano
che io non sappia niente.
Mi fanno domande
senza ascoltare le risposte.
Il senso è sempre lo stesso:
“Che cosa farai da grande?”
Nessuno si chiede che cosa faccio adesso.
Soltanto i grandi fanno?”
Giorgio, 2008.
“Ho 20 anni e devo sbrigarmi
a essere felice.
Dicono che ho tutta la vita davanti.
È una frase minacciosa.
Chissà se se ne rendono conto.
Tutti rimpiangono la giovinezza
ricordando quello che vogliono,
quello che sperano di aver vissuto,
quello che hanno deciso di rimpiangere.
Ma essere giovani certe volte fa paura!
È come vivere in prima linea!”
Terry, 2001.
“Ogni sabato è un incubo.
Ho 18 anni e mi devo divertire,
mi devo innamorare,
mi devo sballare, devo ballare,
devo provare emozioni e passioni,
devo approfittare della mia età
come se fosse la stagione dei saldi!
Devo comprarmi il costume giusto
adesso, subito,
e mi deve calzare a pennello.”
Tommaso, 2003.
“Ho 35 anni e sono appena sbarcato
nell’età centrale della vita.
In questi vent’anni si gioca
tutta la partita.
Il maschio bianco di età
compresa fra i 35 e i 55 anni
è il padrone del mondo,
almeno così mi hanno detto.
E io allora come sono quotato?
Sarò un fallito, uno sconfitto,
un vincente?
Che cosa ho combinato fino ad adesso?”
Christian, 1986.
“Ho 40 anni e devo sbrigarmi
a essere madre.
Adesso o mai più.
C’è qualcosa di sbagliato
se non mi pongo il problema,
c’è qualcosa di sbagliato se me lo pongo,
c’è qualcosa di sbagliato
anche se l’ho risolto.”
Francesca, 1981.
“Ho 60 anni e sono innamorata.
Mi sento ridicola, mi sento fuori posto.
Mi sento come l’imbucata a una festa.
Pare che esista un’età per innamorarsi
e una per ricordarsi
di quando si era innamorate.
Ma chi l’ha detto?”
Lucilla, 1961.
“Ho 80 anni e il mondo intero mi scansa
come un rifiuto solido umano.
Tutta la vita che ho vissuto
non è ricchezza accumulata,
ma usura degli organi, solitudine
dei sentimenti e smemoratezza.
Gli anni che mi restano da vivere
si deprezzano di giorno in giorno
e all’improvviso mi ritrovo tra le mani
soltanto moneta fuori corso.”
Paolo, 1941.
Ho raccolto e riscritto a modo mio
queste testimonianze
per dimostrare che ogni età
ha la sua croce
finché la tua età la subisci
senza mai sporgerti
sul prima o sul dopo,
comunicando con chi lo sta vivendo
quel prima o quel dopo.
Io mi sono rovinata giovinezza e maturità
per la paura di invecchiare.
Ora sono vecchia e felice
come non sono mai stata,
piena di energia, libera.
Onesta, leggera.
Se qualcuno, qualcuno un po’ vecchio,
una simpatica strega sulla settantina
mi avesse avvisata
che la vecchiaia è creta morbida,
che te la puoi modellare addosso
e viverla come ti pare,
sarei stata meno infelice.
Avrei vissuto meglio.
Una società in cui le età della vita
non comunicano fra loro
è una società fragile.
In cui tutti hanno paura del tempo
e quindi del racconto
perché il racconto esiste
soltanto se esiste il tempo.
Tutte le storie incominciano così:
“C’era una volta...”.
Se vogliamo giocare con l’unica vita
che abbiamo a disposizione,
se vogliamo reagire al veleno
dei luoghi comuni,
dobbiamo mescolare le carte,
disordinare le gerarchie
e incontrarci tra diversi.
Uscire insieme dall'incubo del tempo.
Adolescenti e vecchi,
giovani e maturi, maturi e vecchi,
senza ripugnanza per più vecchi
né invidia per i più giovani.
E se qualcuno riesce
a dare testimonianza per noi
del delicato momento del trapasso
bene, meglio, grazie.
Abbiamo bisogno di imparare a morire,
di parlarne,
di immaginare anche l’ultimo
dei paesi stranieri,
il più straniero di tutti.
Se ne parliamo fra giovani e vecchi,
fra adulti e bambini, fra donne e uomini,
avremo meno paura di vivere.
Tutti.
Grazie.
(Applausi)